We are asked to find
the equation that
represents this line.
And the easiest type of equation
to find out based on
just being given a line
is an equation in the
slope-intercept form, which is y
is equal to mx plus b, where
m is the slope and b is the
y-intercept, the y-value of
the coordinate where our graph
intersects the y-axis.
So the y-intercept is
very easy to find.
We can actually figure it out
just by inspecting our graph.
We intersect the y-axis.
That's the y-axis right there.
It wasn't labeled.
Right there, at the point
x is equal to 0.
x is always going to be equal
to 0 at the y-axis.
So x is equal to 0,
y is equal to 3.
So our y-intercept is 3.
And it makes complete sense.
If x is equal to 0, y is equal
to 3, so b is equal to 3.
Now the next thing we need to do
is figure out the slope of
this line, figure out what m
is going to be equal to.
And remember, slope, which is
the same thing as our m or
what m represents, that is
our change in y for a
given change in x.
So let's go from this point to
some other point where we can
definitely figure out its
coordinates, so that looks
like a nice integer coordinate
right there.
And let's figure out what our
change in y and our change in
x was to get there.
So our change in x, we're
starting here at x is equal to
0, we're moving in the positive
x direction by five.
So our change in x
is equal to 5.
One, two, three, four, five.
We went from x is equal to
0 to x is equal to 5.
So our change in x
is equal to 5.
That's our change in x.
Now, what's our change in y?
Well, we have to go down two, so
our change in y-- when our
change in x is positive 5, our
change in y is negative 2.
We're going down.
We're decreasing in y, so our
change in y is negative 2.
So our slope is negative 2/5.
So we figured out the slope.
We figured out the
y-intercept.
We can now write the equation
that represents this line.
It is y is equal to, this
character,, negative 2/5 times
x, that's m right there,
plus b. b is 3.
And we are done!